TI seems to be speaking out against Rob  Kardashian's accusations of a threesome  with blac Chyna TMZ caught up with the  36 year old rapper at Los Angeles  International Airport over the weekend  where he had plenty to say he told the  website quote don't tell women's  business that's bad that's very very bad  poor character flawed and secrets are  sacred  this comes after Rob claimed the rapper  paid Chyna to get intimate with him and  his wife to make a tiny Harris back in  the day during Rob's very public social  media rant last week I personally don't  really agree with the whole thing yeah I  also added he thinks Rob will have a  hard time finding another woman after  what went down between the former  fiance's  [Music]